developing tonight another biden nominee
is under fire for her history of what is
vicious
anti-gop social media posting vanita
gupta is biden's nominee for associate
attorney general
apparently describing last year's
republican national convention of three
nights of racism
xenophobia and other outrageous lies
and by the way was forced to apologize
today during a senate hearing saying
that
she regretted her past harsh rhetoric
another
basically nomination eve conversion we
call it
and it gets worse according to the daily
caller the new
dcc chief technology officer that's the
democratic congressional campaign
committee called on her twitter
followers back in september
to quote burn every cop precinct to the
ground
police killed uh ever her whatever that
means
wow you starting to feel the joe unity
yet here with reaction
fox news contributor dan bongino i'm not
a big believer in the nomination
eve conversions i don't know about you
and i'm trying to be a good christian
i'm not i've got to get better
that's the whole point of being a
christian but i know that we can all be
better i know
i should forgive but i don't really
believe her dan and i maybe that's not
good on my part do you believe her cause
i don't
uh no of course not i mean they have a
vested interest in uh you know running
uh
you know running a series of lies to get
appointed to positions of power
and sean how well did that work out um
appointing hard
partisans to positions in the doj during
the obama administration
i think that broke bad i'm pretty sure
that whole spy gay thing happened even
though wikipedia still calls it a
conspiracy theory
but what is with the democrats by the
way what is with them
and this just hatred for the cops not
all of them i don't want to stereotype
them like they do to us
but why is it that this defund the
police we hate the cops thing is almost
exclusively
um a bastion of far left-wing activism
you don't see it on the right i mean you
wouldn't even be accepted in the
conservative community
with an you know instinct to want to
paint the cops with this broad brush
that they're evil awful people
what is it on the left well you know i
want to add one more thing on this
i covered on my show a little while ago
i think last week
a story in new york magazine or the new
yorker again no like right wing outlet
where some liberal pollster was trying
to kind of hot wash the 2020 election
and what went right and wrong for trump
he's a liberal keep that in mind
and he said the one issue sean the one
issue that did the most
damage to the democrats in the hispanic
and black community
what do you think it was defund the
police
that's because liberals treat minority
voters like idiots
it is the soft bigotry of low
expectations they're the real racists
they treat them like robots black and
hispanic voters have the exact same
concerns we do for their kids
and their communities they're no
different than we are that may be news
to the left listening to the show
democratic governors and mayors that
don't keep their city safe and secure
don't insure law and order and don't fix
our broken schools
they have hurt communities
in this country and it's time for
republicans to go into these communities
and fix those problems and then they
will get elected
in bigger numbers that's my view yeah i
mean look rudy you know rudy giuliani
cleaned up new york sean
he won re-election by what was it 12
points or 15 points
shocking number yeah yeah yeah
all right by the way i am still giddy
over your healthiness we're so thankful
you're the man brother thank you for
sticking with me through the whole thing
you're a good man brother we're very
happy for you and we're glad you're back
stronger than ever watch out the world
there that man
is is full on the octagon next
paper we're going to the octagon all
right thank you my friend